Imagine opening up, you know, a really groundbreaking scientific paper, like one that completely solves this massive computational bottleneck in biology. You scan down the author list because you want to see who the brilliant lead engineer is, right? And you see Claude.
Yeah, it really is a moment.
Not, you know, a human researcher who used an AI as a fancy calculator. We're talking about an AI acting as the lead software engineer and the actual first author.
It completely breaks the mental model we have for how scientific progress is supposed to happen, right? We are so used to this very clear hierarchy. Humans are the architects, they design the solutions, and then the computers just, well, they execute the code.
Right, exactly.
So to see a machine listed as the first author on a... major, highly technical achievement. I mean, it really feels like we're crossing a very strange, very significant threshold here.
And that threshold is exactly what we are exploring in today's Deep Dive. The whole thing centers on a brand new technical report from Ampropic. It's dated September 17th, 2026, and it's titled Accelerating Open Source Biomolecular Models with Claude. Which is quite
a title. It is. Now, I should mention we do have a few older background papers on the desk today, things from 2021 and 2022 about protein folding theory and hardware engineering. But we're only bringing those in to explain the
foundation that this new paper stands on. The spotlight today is squarely on the September Anthropic Report.
Right, because our mission today is really to unpack how a frontier AI model took the world's most complex biological software and just made it radically faster. We want to look at the mechanics of how it actually did that and the implications for the
pace of scientific discovery.
And the caveats, right? Because there are always caveats.
Always. There are some very real caveats hidden in the benchmark data that we definitely need to get into.
For sure. But before we get into all the heavy biological math, I want to say this directly to you listening. Even if you, you know, don't know the first thing about computational biology or maybe you don't care about protein folding at all, you really need to pay attention to this. Because this isn't just a biology story. It's a
glimpse into the immediate future of how all knowledge work. especially complex software engineering might soon be done so let's just start with the sheer scale of the claim here what exactly did they ask this model to do
okay so they basically pointed Claude at this massive pile of other people's scientific software specifically all these open source models that scientists use every single day to you know predict protein structures model DNA design
new biological molecule
heavy lifting stuff
Exactly. And they just asked Claude to make that software run faster. And the result is honestly staggering. In just under four weeks, Claude produced highly optimized packages for 36 different model implementations.
Wow. Yeah,
which covers more than 30 distinct open source biomolecular models.
30 distinct code bases in four weeks. I mean, to ground that for anyone who maybe doesn't work in software engineering, the paper plainly states that optimizing these kinds of highly complex specialized models normally takes an experienced human engineering team weeks per single model.
And the worst part is the optimization you do for one model, it usually doesn't even transfer to the next one. So it's just this bespoke, grueling work every time.
Because it requires a really rare intersection of skills. You need a deep understanding of the weird biological math the model is trying to execute. But you also need a highly specialized understanding of the physical hardware architecture, like how the
GPU actually operates.
Right, the hardware level. But the human supervision here was wildly minimal. I mean, the paper says Claude was overseen by just two scientists. And while those two scientists understood biomolecular modeling, they had zero experience in inference optimization or
kernel engineering.
Not at all.
They literally did not possess the technical skills to do the work they were supervising.
Which brings us right back to that authorship line you mentioned. The first author on this technical report is literally Claude Science. The AI performed the optimization, it conducted the data analysis, and it actually drafted the report itself.
Well, the humans just kind of watched.
The human supervisors essentially just pointed it in the right direction and validated the outputs. It's acting as a senior principal software engineer.
It's crazy, but to really appreciate how wild that is, we can't just marvel at the speed of it all. We have to look at the mechanics. How did it actually speed up these models? Because from what I understand, there was this massive compute traffic jam inherent to this
whole field of biology, and Claude somehow cleared it.
Yeah. To understand that traffic jam, we really have to look back at one of our background papers. This is the famous Alpha Fold 2 paper from 2021 by Jumper et al.
Right. The big breakthrough.
Huge breakthrough. It changed biology forever because it introduced an architectural idea that made accurate protein structure prediction possible in the first place. They introduced these mathematical operations called triangle attention and triangle multiplication.
Okay, let's pause right there. Why triangle operations? Because proteins are usually just explained to us as like strings of amino acids, right?
They start as strings, yes, but in the real world, they fold up into these highly complex 3D shapes. And to predict that shape, the AI model has to reason about spatial geometry. It has to figure out how every single piece of that string relates to
every other piece in three-dimensional space. So these triangle updates allow the model to update the representation of any two amino acids based on their relationship to a third one. So it literally creates a spatial triangle.
Ah,
I see. And by 2024, the Alpha Fold 3 paper took this concept, generalized it to handle all sorts of biomolecular interactions, and created what they called the pairformer architecture, which is why most open source models today share some version of that exact architecture.
Okay, so this architectural idea that made the entire field successful is now the very thing causing the compute traffic jam.
Precisely. The math behind these triangle updates is incredibly punishing. The compute cost is cubic in the number of tokens, meaning the amino acids or atoms you're trying to model.
OK, wait. Cubic meaning. If I have a protein that is twice as large, the compute doesn't just double, right? It goes up by two times two times two. It goes up eightfold.
Yes. The math scales terribly. It's a cubic curve. So when researchers try to study really large, complex biological systems, they just hit this massive computational wall. It becomes way too expensive and way too slow to calculate.
But you can't just change the math, right? Like if you change the math, you break the spatial reasoning and then the biology fails.
You absolutely cannot change the math. So what you have to change is how the physical hardware executes that math. And this brings us to the theory of modern GPU kernel engineering. This is laid out in another background paper, the 2022 Flash Attention paper by Dowell
et al.
Flash Attention, right. I've heard of this.
Yeah, it's legendary in this space. So a GPU kernel is essentially a very low level program that tells the graphics card exactly how to move data around and execute operations. And the theory from 2022 relies on something called IO
awareness.
Which means what exactly?
It basically means keeping your data in the fastest possible memory on the chip and fusing multiple small mathematical operations into one single efficient step.
Okay. I want to try to visualize this hardware problem because it can get pretty abstract, let's say. Let's say I'm a chef, okay? And I represent the GPU. And I'm trying to bake a massive, really complex cake, which represents this whole cubic math
problem. Okay, I like this. Go with it.
Without custom kernels, the old way of doing this is like I have to walk down this incredibly long hallway to a giant walk-in fridge just to grab one single egg.
Yes. And that walk-in fridge represents the GPU's main memory, which is called HBM. It has huge capacity, so it holds all your ingredients, but it is physically further away from the processor and very slow to access.
Right. So I get my one egg. I walk all the way back up the hallway to my prep counter and I crack it into the bowl. Then I look at the recipe and realize I need flour. So I walk all the way down the hall to the fridge again. Like the travel time is completely destroying my cooking efficiency.
which is exactly where kernel engineering comes in. The flash attention theory taught us that you write a kernel that gives the chef a much better set of instructions. It says, hey, go to the walk-in fridge exactly once, grab the entire carton of eggs, grab all the flour,
the sugar, the butter, bring it all back to your prep counter at the exact same time.
And the prep counter in this analogy is the fast on-ship memory.
Yes, the SRAM. It's much smaller than the giant fridge, but it's incredibly fast because it's right there where the math is actually happening. So you mix all the ingredients together in one bowl.
Which is the fusing of the operations.
Exactly. You fuse the operations before you ever send the finished batter back down the hall to the slow memory.
That makes perfect sense. You're just eliminating the commute. And so this is exactly what Claude did for biology.
It is. Claude wrote its own custom GPU kernels specifically for those brutal biological triangle operations. And they deliberately named these kernels flash pair former, which is a very clear nod to that flash tension lineage we just talked about.
That's so cool. And how did they actually perform?
The benchmarks for Flash Pairformer version 1 are honestly incredible. They tested Claude's kernels against NVIDIA's own field-standard GUCO variants
kernel.
For triangle attention, Claude's code ran 2.7 times faster at a pair width of 128. 1 in 28 is the standard width used by major models like also Fold 3 and Bolt 2.
And what if you push it wider, like to 256, which I think models like Pertenex V2
use? At 256, it was 2.9 times faster. And the triangle multiplication operations saw speed ups of 1.7x and 3.2x.
Wow.
But we really need to acknowledge the tension here. The 2022 Flash Intention paper was a celebrated massive human research contribution. Brilliant human engineers build entire highly lucrative careers on their ability to write these fused IO-aware kernels.
Oh yeah, it's an elite skill.
And this anthropic paper treats that exact shape of elite engineering work as basically a chore, a task to be delegated to an AI over a few weeks.
It's kind of sobering, really. But, you know, speed for the sake of speed is just a parlor trick. What does all this custom kernel engineering actually buy a biologist who's just sitting at their computer trying to do their work? Because the paper outlines three distinct optimization modes that
Claude delivered for every package, right?
Exact.
Fast and big.
Right. Let's start with exact mode. So this mode is designed to reproduce the unmodified model's outputs bit for bit.
So no changes to the numbers at all.
Zero compromise on the math. And just by scheduling the operations better on the hardware, exact mode ran 1.6 times faster on average across 14 different structure prediction models.
A 1.6x speedup basically for free. But fast mode is where the numbers really start to jump, right?
They do. Fast mode trades a very, very tiny bit of numerical precision in exchange for raw speed. And across 13 different models, fast mode ran 4.1 times faster on average.
Four times faster on average. That's huge.
And it varied depending on the code base, too. For a model called OpenDD, it was 2.3 times faster. But for Chai1, it was a massive 6.4 times faster.
OK, but if I'm a scientist and you tell me my model is suddenly running four or six times faster, but you traded away some of my numerical precision to do it, I mean, my immediate question is, did you just break my science? Like, are the structural predictions still actually accurate?
Which is the only question that matters. If the output is garbage, I don't care how fast it is. So to prove the science remained intact, the authors conducted a massive accuracy audit using a benchmark called FoldBenchLight. They pooled data over 13
model configurations, testing 1,925 different model target pairs.
And what exactly are they measuring in that audit? How do you prove it didn't break?
They looked at the share of acceptably predicted biological interfaces. They measured this using something called a DOCQ score.
Which operates on what kind of scale?
Think of a DOCQ score of 1.0 as a perfect, flawless match to physical reality. Getting a score of 0.23 or higher means the model successfully predicted the basic biological interface. It got the shape right enough to be practically useful.
Okay, got it. So they tracked how many predictions hit that 0.23 threshold before and after Claude's optimization.
Exactly. And the result, the share of acceptable predictions changed by less than one percentage point in every single mode.
Less than 1%.
Statistically, the pooled change was indistinguishable from zero. So the audit proves that the speedups are real and the scientific integrity of the models remains completely intact.
Okay, so fast mode proves the speed is safe. But you mentioned a third mode earlier, big mode. If fast is about speed, what on earth is big mode doing?
Big mode isn't primarily about speed at all. It's about aggressively reducing peak memory usage. Because remember that cubic math problem we talked about?
Right, the eight-fold increase.
Exactly. When you try to model something truly massive, the GPU literally runs out of memory trying to hole all those intermediate calculations at once, and it just crashes. Big mode uses clever techniques like chunking the data and recomputing intermediate steps on the fly
to drastically lower that memory footprint. It extends what can physically fit on the hardware.
Which means we can finally model things we previously just couldn't fit on a chip.
Precisely. BigMode allowed for accurate predictions of massive molecular machines. We're talking structures over 10,000 tokens on just a single node of eight GPUs. They successfully modeled the human mitochondrial complex I, the E.
coli 70S ribosome, and phosphocatalyse.
Wow.
And why is that such a big deal for the field?
Because that is the scale of actual biological function and disease. We aren't just looking at isolated, tiny toy proteins anymore. We're looking at massive biological engines that normally require huge, incredibly expensive supercomputing clusters to even attempt to
model. And big mode makes modeling them accessible on much, much smaller hardware footprints.
But they didn't stop at 10,000 tokens, did they? The paper mentions they pushed Big Mode to see exactly where it would break, and it includes this really fascinating, very transparent failure.
Yeah, they wanted to find the absolute limit, so they pushed Big Mode to try and model entire viral capsids. These are colossal structures of up to 70,320 residues. And they ran this on eight ultra-high-end B300 GPUs.
Let me guess. The GPUs finally ran out of memory and crashed.
See, that's the fascinating part. The GPUs did not crash.
Wait, really?
Every single run completed.
Yeah.
The hardware and Claude's kernel optimizations worked flawlessly.
All right.
But every single prediction completely collapsed. The models just spit out these dense, physically impossible, interpenetrating balls of protein. The TM scores were catastrophic.
OK, let's define the TM score for the audience really quickly, because the numbers in the paper are 0.14 and 0.08.
Right. So a TM score measures structural accuracy on a scale from 0 to 1. A score of 1.0 is a perfect match. Anything below 0.2 is essentially a random jumble of atoms. So 0.08 is a complete failure to predict anything biologically meaningful at all.
So wait, if the hardware didn't crash and the optimization worked perfectly, why did the biology fail so badly?
The authors lay out this distinction perfectly, and it is, honestly, the sharpest line in the entire paper. You really have to sit with this concept. Big mode extends what can be computed, not what the models have learned.
Ah, I see. So Claude basically built a perfectly functioning, massive eight-lane superhighway, but the AI models driving on it had never actually been taught how to navigate a vehicle that large.
That's exactly it. The underlying AI models simply hadn't learned how to predict structures that massive because their training data never included biological assemblies anywhere near that size. The compute limit has been removed, but the biological knowledge limit remains.
That is such a crucial distinction to make. But, you know, even with those knowledge limits on the massive structures, the economic impact of these speed ups on normal sized proteins is staggering, especially when we look at the final test in the paper, which was designing entirely new proteins
from scratch.
Right, binder design. To understand the economics here, we have to pull from our last two background papers. First, there's the 2025 Bindcraft paper. That paper established the human baseline for how incredibly difficult and computationally expensive one-shot binder
design is. Designing a protein to bind to a specific target is incredibly hard.
And then the second baseline is Anthropic's own paper from just a month prior to this one, so August 2026. In that August paper, they used Claude to run autonomous campaigns to design these protein binders. And the cost was steep. They were spending up to
$10,000 of cloud GPU time per target.
$10,000. I mean, that is just massive campaign scale compute. So the researchers took the newly optimized models, combined them with a simplified experimental protocol, and basically asked Claude to run the binder design task again.
And the result is almost hard to believe. Using just one clod model on one single H200 GPU for just 24 hours, it produced de novo, meaning entirely new protein binders. And the in silico IPSAE scores of these new binders completely match
the output of those earlier $10,000 campaigns.
We really need to make sure the math lands for the listener here. The cost to achieve the exact same predictive score dropped from roughly $10,000 per target down to about $150.
That is roughly 100 times less GPU usage. Two orders of magnitude cost drop in a single month. I mean, if you extrapolate that across an entire pharmaceutical pipeline, you're talking about saving millions of dollars and years of compute time.
It is a massive leap. But as with any major scientific claim, we have to look at the tensions and the disagreements. Because 100x cost drop and a robot-first author, it sounds like a perfect sci-fi utopia. But the reality is always
more nuanced.
Definitely. So let's dismantle the hype a bit, because that 100x number has a pretty big asterisk attached to it. The paper is honest about it, to be fair, but they didn't actually separate the variables perfectly.
No, they didn't. Claude didn't just use the optimized, faster models. The team also used a simplified, more efficient agentic protocol for how the experiment was managed.
Right. So we don't actually know how much of that 100x cost drop is purely from the biological code running faster and how much is just from the new protocol being smarter. It's a combined, confounded variable.
Exactly. And we also need to be crystal clear about what an in silico APBSAE score actually is.
Yes, let's emphasize that. No actual physical protein was manufactured in this study.
None. Zero. And silico literally means it happened on a silicon computer chip, not in a wet lab. The IPSAE score is a digital prediction that these proteins will bind successfully in the real physical world. And yeah, those predictive scores match
the $10,000 baseline. But until someone actually synthesizes these proteins in a laboratory test tube, and physically tests them, it remains a highly educated digital guess.
There's also this fundamental tension in how they chose to benchmark their speedups. Whenever a paper says we beat the default baseline, you always have to ask, well, who chose the default?
And the authors admit they chose the baseline. They defined it as the fastest correct configuration we could find, which, you know, it's a subjective judgment call.
Right. For instance, they measured their 4.1x average speedup for a model called CoLabFold against version 1.6.1 of that software. But later releases of CoLabFold actually added their own fused kernels written by human engineers.
Exactly. Yeah. So it raises a very fair question. How much of that massive speed up is Claude being this transcendent coding genius? And how much of it is just the fact that open source scientific code, which is usually written by academics who aren't software engineers, is often
just unoptimized and clunky to begin with?
It's probably a mix of both. And to their credit, the authors don't hide their failures. If you dig into the supplementary information, the SI section of the paper, they document a few model checks that simply didn't pass the accuracy thresholds. It wasn't a 100% flawless
victory across all 36 implementations.
Acknowledging those failures is good science. But it brings us to this massive, unresolved tension that is being actively debated in the scientific community this very week. It goes right back to the authorship question. The report literally says Claude performed the optimization work
and data analysis described here and drafted this report under human supervision.
So what does peer review even mean anymore? Like peer review relies on human experts validating the methodology of other human experts. But the methodology here was essentially a four week chat log with a chat bot. And the two human supervisors didn't
even have the kernel engineering expertise to write the code the AI produced.
It creates a total paradox. How can the supervisors or the peer reviewers adequately review the AI's complex hardware code if they can't write it themselves? They're essentially forced to rely purely on the output, the fact that the fold bench scores didn't drop,
to prove that the invisible AI-generated math is actually correct. It fundamentally changes the nature of scientific trust.
Which is why when we pull back and look at the entire landscape of this deep dive, the ultimate takeaway isn't really about biology at all.
Not at all. Biology is just the field where the camera happened to be pointing this month. The true result, the thing that should make everyone sit up and take notice, is that a frontier model did weeks of highly specialized, incredibly dense engineering work
across 30 different code bases it had never seen before. And it was supervised by people who could not have done that work themselves. The barrier to executing elite level technical optimization just drastically lowered.
And then that is exactly the thought I want to leave you with today. We started by picturing that traditional hierarchy of innovation, right? Human experts designing, computers executing. This paper just flipped that hierarchy entirely on its head, replacing the lead engineer with an AI
model. So I want you to think about your own job, your own industry. If an AI can jump into 30 alien, highly complex scientific code bases and optimize them better than human specialists can in just a matter of weeks, What could it do to the software, the logistics,
or the foundational bottlenecks of your industry if you just gave it a month?